Vice President Mike Pence's wife Karen
pence recently moved there's a true
story 20,000 bees into the vice
presidential residence in Washington DC
this is a true story yes yes Karen pence
brings 20,000 bees to the vice
president's home now you might be
wondering where Karen pens got all those
bees the answer happens to be one of our
show's new sponsors take a look are you
a Christian wife who's interested in
beekeeping of course you are why not get
your hobby on a godly footing at
Christian bees calm a Christian bees we
screen all our hives took the Jewish
Buddhist Muslim bees or gay bees out of
your college the bees are hand baptized
and separated by gender until marriage
and once they're bred all the eggs are
carried to term and RV's died of natural
causes they don't believe in climate
change order today and Christian bees
calm will ship the bees directly to your
home in these specially designed
canisters perfect for when your husband
is away on his increasingly longer
business trips Christian bees calm hear
that
you're pretty
[Applause]
you